Bonjour! Aujourd'hui on va parler des troubadours!
-Encore un épisode pour Aliénor, formidable...
-Ben, je te rappelle que je suis médiéviste
à la base, alors non je parle pas trop de
ton époque, désolé, je maîtrise pas assez
le sujet...
-Ça, c'est bien vrai.
-C'est quoi un troubadour?
-Vraiment?
-Des poètes qui sont un peu devenus un archétype
du Moyen Âge, on en croise dans toutes les
pseudo fêtes médiévales même s'ils ne
parlent pas un mot d'occitan...
-Connaît pô.
-Les trouvères, alors, ça te dis quelque
chose?
-Ah ouais, bon y'en a déjà plus à mon époque
hein, mais j'connais!
-Parfait, ben on n'a qu'à parler des deux!
Les troubadours sont souvent associés à
de pauvres chanteurs allant de châteaux en
châteaux pour exercer leur art, et la plupart
des chants médiévaux leur sont associés
alors qu'en réalité, pas du tout.
Les troubadours ne représentent qu'un mouvement
poétique temporaire, de la fin du XIe à
la fin du XIIIe siècle, et localisé.
La poésie des troubadours naît à la fin
du XIe siècle à la cour de Poitiers, le
premier troubadour connu étant Guillaume
IX, duc d'Aquitaine.
Pas vraiment un loisir de pécore, donc.
Durant sa jeunesse il a étudié la musique
dans les écoles épiscopales, et il s'inspire
des hymnes liturgiques et de la poésie latine
et arabe pour composer des vers qu'il chante
lui-même.
Ne parlant pas l'occitan je ne vais pas vous
faire l'affront d'en réciter un extrait,
mais c'était plutôt joli.
Voyez plutôt.
-Je peux chanter si vous voulez!
-NON/NON.
-De sa cour, l'art des troubadours se répand
en Aquitaine, en Limousin et en Provence,
soit dans toutes les régions de langue d'Oc
puisque c'est la langue dans laquelle sont
rédigés ces poèmes.
Le mot «troubadour» vient de l'occitan
trobar qui signifie «trouver», «poétiser».
Les premiers troubadours sont surtout des
grands seigneurs, comme Jaufré Rudel ou Bertran
de Born, de petits chevaliers comme Raimbaut
de Vaqueiras...
-On compte aussi une vingtaine de femmes trobairitz,
comme la comtesse Béatrice de Die ou Azalaïs
de Porcaraigues.
-En tout on dénombre 460 troubadours entre
1100 et 1280, dont une centaine nous sont
connus grâce aux vida, des biographies de
troubadours souvent posthumes et donc assez
romancées.
En dehors des grands seigneurs qui composent
pour le plaisir, la plupart des troubadours
sont des courtisans qui dépendent du mécénat
de leur seigneur pour vivre.
Certaines cours deviennent des centres culturels
importantes, comme celle d'Eble II de Ventadorn
qui crée une école de l'art poétique dans
sa seigneurie du Limousin.
-Devenir le protecteur de troubadours est
un signe de réussite et de goût.
Leur présence est prétexte à l'organisation
de fêtes destinées à impressionner l'aristocratie
locale.
-La renommée des troubadours va aussi de
paire avec l'émergence d'un nouvel art de
vivre dans les cours du début du XIIe siècle,
qui met en avant le faste et la courtoisie.
Des notions chantées et véhiculées par
les troubadours.
Parmi les cours les plus en vogue, celle d'Aliénor
d'Aquitaine, petite-fille du premier troubadour
Guillaume IX d'Aquitaine, contribue à diffuser
l'art du trobar au-delà des terres du Midi.
En effet, elle épouse d'abord le roi de France
Louis VII, puis le roi d'Angleterre Henri
Plantagenêt, et reçoit des troubadours dans
toutes les cours où elle s'installe.
-Elle transmet sa passion à ses enfants qui
épousent à leur tour plein de gens importants
un peu partout en Europe, et paf, ça fait
des troubadours.
-Bref, on a vu comment les troubadours apparaissent,
mais que font-ils de leurs journées, finalement?
La poésie des troubadours repose avant tout
sur la fin'amor, amour courtois en langue
d'oïl.
C'est un art d'aimer qui repose sur la joie,
la patience et la mesure.
Par exemple certains troubadours amoureux
de dames de la noblesse composent pour elles
des chants dans lesquels ils anonymisent leur
nom, ou vont même jusqu'à oser un peu d'érotisme.
-Qui prend la forme d'un baiser ou du don
d'un anneau.
Ça reste plutôt soft.
-La fin'amor, c'est avant tout une exaltation
de l'esprit, on évite de parler de nudité
ou d'adultère réel.
D'abord poésie, il devient un art de vivre
commenté à la cour et faisant l'objet de
débats.
En 1185, André le Chapelain rédige De l'art
honnête d'aimer et de la réprobation de
l'amour dans lequel il déclare: «Le
vrai amour est toujours timide.
Il ne dort ni ne mange, celui que passion
d'amour tourmente.»
-N'est-ce pas Aliénor? Ton vrai amour était
plutôt timide.
-Mais je pouvais pas savoir que sire Godefroy...
-On reste concentrées? La poésie des troubadours
peut prendre plusieurs formes, toutes très
codifiées.
Les canson par exemple sont des chansons d'amour
accompagnées d'une mélodie;
-Les sirventès sont des chants satiriques,
politiques ou moraux, qui s'inspirent de l'actualité
ou des mœurs de l'époque.
Peire Cardinal, par exemple, raconte dans
sa vida qu'il composa maints sirventès où
il blâmait fort les folies de ce monde, la
corruption du clergé et les vices de la noblesse.
-Le planh déplore la mort d'un grand personnage
ou d'une amante.
-L'alba annonce la séparation de deux amants
au lever du jour.
-La ballade est faite pour danser.
-Et les pastourelles sont des pièces rustiques,
dans lesquelles un chevalier séduit une bergère.
Quelle faute de goût.
-Et alors attendez que deux troubadours se
rencontrent! Ils se lancent alors dans des
défis poétiques, les tensons ou jocs partits,
des joutes verbales où ils doivent chacun
en musique défendre leurs arguments sur un
sujet choisi.
À la fin du XIIIe siècle, la poésie des
troubadours décline.
La croisade contre les cathares en terre d'Oc
et l'arrivée de l'Inquisition modifient les
mœurs de la société courtoise.
Les chansons d'amours disparaissent au profit
des chansons mariales, religieuses, et l'amour
courtois devient beaucoup trop subversif pour
être chanté.
Les derniers troubadours, dans les années
1290, s'installent en Italie, en Aragon ou
en Castille pour continuer leur art.
Mais la fin des troubadours ne signifie pas
la fin de la poésie! Dès le second tiers
du XIIe siècle, on rencontre les troubadours
dans certaines cours du nord, je vous ai par
exemple parlé de celles d'Aliénor d'Aquitaine
en France puis en Angleterre.
La culture chevaleresque et courtoise se répand
dans les cours de Flandre, de Champagne, de
Picardie, d'Artois, et donne naissance à
de nouveaux poètes: les trouvères.
-Littéralement l'équivalent en langue d'oïl
des troubadours.
Trobar, trouvère.
-Comme les troubadours, beaucoup de trouvères
sont issus de la noblesse ou sont des courtisans.
On peut citer parmi les premiers Chrétien
de Troyes, Huon d'Oisy, Gace Brulé...
La mode des trouvères se répand en Bretagne
avec les lais bretons à la fin du XIIe siècle,
et même en Allemagne avec les minnesänger.
À partir du XIIIe siècle, la bourgeoisie
de Flandre et d'Artois se prend au jeu et
donne un nouvel élan à la poésie des trouvères.
Leurs styles de chants s'inspirent de celui
des troubadours: le grand chant pour la
canta, l'aube pour l'alba et le serventois
pour le sirventès.
La pastourelle est aussi très répandue,
ainsi que de nouveaux chants qui leur sont
propres:
-La reverdie, un chant de printemps.
-La chanson de toile, un petit drame d'amour.
-La rotruenge, un chant à refrain.
-Le motet, une polyphonie vocale.
-La fatrasie joue surtout avec les mots.
-Les congés sont des poèmes d'adieu de lépreux
à leur ville natale
-Les chansons de croisades sont sur des gens
qui partent en croisade.
-Les trouvères étant pour beaucoup des bourgeois
des villes, à partir du XIIIe siècle, ils
s'organisent en confréries comme n'importe
quel corps de métier.
La ville d'Arras, par exemple, compte environ
80 poètes dont le seigneur Hue d'Arras himself!
Les confréries instaurent des concours de
poésie lyrique, les puys, dont les gagnants
sont nommés «princes» ou «rois».
-Le plus ancien concours est le Puy verd d'Arras,
fondé en 1194.
-Et le plus grand gagnant est le poète Jehan
Brodel, qui participe à 99 puys et en est
régulièrement nommé prince.
-Au XIVe siècle, Guillaume de Machaut est
l'un des derniers trouvères connus.
Il rédige 235 ballades, 21 rondeaux, 33 virelais,
la première messe à quatre voix, et innove
en n'associant plus systématiquement la musique
à sa poésie.
Parce que les troubadours et trouvères ne
déclamaient pas forcément eux-même leurs
vers, et ne jouaient pas forcément d'un instrument!
Pour cela ils se faisaient accompagner de
musiciens chanteurs appelés ménestrels ou
jongleurs.
Chaque troubadour a un ou plusieurs ménestrels
à son service.
Ils doivent savoir rimer, parler, chanter,
lire à voix haute, jouer d'au moins neuf
instruments de musique, faire des acrobaties,
imiter le chant des oiseaux...
D'autres ménestrels ne sont pas attachés
à un troubadour ou à un trouvère mais sont
au service d'un prince et l'accompagnent dans
tous ses déplacements.
-Ce métier se retrouve aussi dans les foires
et les villes, mais on les appelle alors «bateleurs»
ou «histrions».
-Au XIVe siècle, les ménestrels se rassemblent
en corporation sous l'autorité d'un «roi
des ménestrels». La plus vieille corporation
est celle de Paris, créée en 1321, qui fixe
la durée d'apprentissage des jeunes ménestrels
à six ans.
Les corporations de ménestrels organisent
leurs propres concours lyriques et ont quelques
privilèges, comme le droit de traverser le
Petit-Pont de Paris contre une chanson.
-Eh tu chantes?
-C'est payé?
-Non mais tu pourras traverser un pont!
Ça sera super pour ta visibilité.
… Ok.
-De tous les poèmes déclamés par les troubadours,
environ 2500 demeurent, mis par écrit entre
vingt et cent ans après leur composition.
Les trouvères, pour leur part, nous ont laissé
environ 2100 poèmes et 4000 mélodies.
Le rythme et le détail de l'accompagnement
musical, par contre, ne nous sont pas parvenus.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, si
vous voulez en savoir plus vous pouvez trouver
quelques infos supplémentaires dans le livre
La Vie Quotidienne au Moyen Âge de...
Justine Defrance, mais c'est moi!
Et tant qu'on est dans les trucs faits par
moi, on peut dire que les troubadours et les
trouvères offraient du divertissement, tout
comme moi avec Time Warp dont la saison 2
est en cours de financement participatif!
Donc si vous aviez aimé la saison 1, si vous
aimez l'histoire, l'humour, les voyages dans
le temps, si vous aimez ce que je fait sur
Internet, vous pouvez consulter le lien Ulule
qui s'affiche et que vous retrouverez dans
la description, le partager, et même donner
un peu de sous si vous le souhaitez, cela
nous aiderait grandement.
Vous seriez tels les seigneurs mécènes des
arts d'antan, et ça c'est classe.
À bientôt pour un épisode de Gentes Dames
Badass, merci de votre attention et portez-vous
bien!